doing international ones too that was a
really interesting project it was one of
these projects that never came to us it
wasn't something we planned
I had just for years been collecting
personality data on the web and and we
had you know literally hundreds of
thousands of personality surveys and my
student was just you know he's just has
this intuitive knack for something was
interesting and he and we had never
thought of it he just thought okay let's
go and see if there are differences in
the states of personality and so then
since we did find some differences he
started collecting zip code data so we
could get much more finely tuned
portraits we have the stereotype right
about the laid-back dude Californians
and the uptight Woody Allen neurotic New
Yorkers so we were looking at are there
differences in neuroticism and that's
one of the ones that shows up most
cleanly is we see yes indeed there are
the there if you look at the the map of
the country the the Northeast is higher
neuroticism and the Southwest is Laura
neuroticism so and these are very small
differences but they're reliable
differences you know of course not
everybody in New York is neurotic but on
average they're more neurotic than the
average Californian and openness to we
found some really nice findings with
openness which is really what's linked
to rigid Florida's findings in terms of
because that's the ones really
associated with creativity and so there
you find high openness which is you know
are people interested in abstract ideas
philosophical intellectual
about you tend to find that but down the
coasts and then there's pretty much no
much going on in the middle with one or
two